these are the invisible victims of a
pandemic caught up in a 40-day lockdown
with no work and earnings hundreds of
men women and then children wait in the
Blazing Sun for a precious meal any help
is God send millions of daily wage
earners contract workers and migrant
labor have been affected the worst the
shutdown has stripped them of everything
including their dignity I'm talking as a
vote we are like stray dogs looking for
food begging everyone if we get we will
eat or otherwise we will starve most
here are migrants who came for a better
life without work little or no savings
and an uncertain future they are
desperate to go back home they live in a
cluster of one-room homes some even in
tin sheds social distancing is a
privilege they cannot afford with common
washing areas and no personal protection
the pandemic would ravage hundreds here
Miriam gave birth to her son during the
lockdown and is worried they have no
money for a medical emergency her
neighbor Tanuja is distressed for her
two children she's left behind thousands
of miles away in Beijing this disease
has crushed us no money to pay but we do
no work no food I have to send money
back to the village for my children what
can we do food is the biggest problem
all these people face
driving back home vishal anand a
restauranteur witnessed people begging
for food from strangers he pulled in his
finances and with a group of his friends
and volunteers started a kitchen making
thousands of hot meals with limited
resources the idea was to provide the
most vulnerable only for a few days but
with the overwhelming numbers of hungry
people they were unable to stop first
and foremost things that secure them
with basic you know food and ration for
for the next 90 days that's most
important because we really don't know
when the logged on gets over and when
will they get back to their respective
jobs with the help of some charities and
donations this citizens group is making
life a bit easier for the thousands of
the Forgotten poor never Lazarus Sky
News Google